uh i i think what else is dope about
your gym and one one of the
literally the original reason i went in
hey i knew you were doing your thing
but then also you kind of fighting back
against the city
yeah and you know they're trying to you
know in la for those of you that live in
l.a
they shut down all gyms all gyms except
for zoo jim
because you fought back yeah how has
your experience been with that
because it's a beast man like i'm sure
you're fighting the good fight i think
yeah because obviously one way to beat
covet is be healthy
and this promotes health and there's no
outbreaks and it's
so it's a tricky thing yeah it's crazy
right now because like
there now there's all these studies
coming out too about how like like 63
of people who like actually ended up you
know dying from covid like or it's more
like directly related to health and
exercise like not doing so
underlying healthy questions and like
like legit studies coming out saying
like we should have encouraged people to
do that
instead of not do that but dude i got a
ticket for riding my bike
yeah i mean listen with this it sucks
it's like i can't say so much but i can
say like
i definitely you don't have to yeah i i
definitely
it's not right what they're doing
because i mean we've spoken about this
man and it's just
uh this is my simple thing like i really
just want to stand up and i want to talk
to the judge i want to talk to the jury
i want to ask him like
if because we might end up getting there
i might go to like a jury trial
i think what's interesting is you're
fighting this fight you're fighting the
good fight
but by the time it gets to that
everything's in me open yeah who are
they fighting for
that point yeah you know what i'm saying
like and then texas opened today yeah
and you've got mississippi
[ __ ] newsom is that he's like that's
directly he's like reckless like
well because he but he lit chill out but
no
can't backtrack now like he has to
double down on that's
why everybody's business but this is
like [ __ ] i just want to make this
this this the cigarette thing well go
ahead this is the thing that i don't
understand right
if we as humans individuals we can make
the choice
because i don't want to talk about
alcohol because everyone's going to be
like well alcohol people are alcohol
dependent if you take alcohol away from
them they'll die and
because you you if you were an alcoholic
and you were dependent on alcohol and
someone took it away from you
you die yeah like years of alcohol abuse
to like take it away you have a heart
attack you your body's wrong
granted everyone else who's not alcohol
dependent
then maybe they don't need to go get
alcohol like if we're trying to
determine what's good for people in the
public health right because the public
health officials are telling me that
my gym is a problem by telling me it
should be closed right
but at the same time like can you can
they also explain to me
there's two things i want to talk about
why is it okay for us to make decisions
as individuals to go
buy cigarettes that cause
like the three things that are making
people die of complications with cover
like most people who die from covet are
dying because of covid
but because of these three other
conditions which is high blood pressure
diabetes and cholesterol heart disease
right and those which facts well those
are fats those are likely
and that's the thing i'm pretty sure you
would like you that
a person that runs a gym a facility
where people to go
people go to work on their health i'm
pretty sure you would look up
as much statistics as you could but
these are facts yeah
yeah i'm not saying like these are these
are they're like released facts from
the cdc and all these are the things
that are killing people in combination
with covet right
those three things are caused by
cigarettes not only to you smoking them
but to people who around you secondhand
smoke but it's an okay choice
for us to buy that cigarette to smoke it
to kill myself like to cause these
issues the government's giving you that
freedom yeah and him to make that
freedom's okay
but it's not okay for me to make the
choice to go to the gym
to combat those same three things to
defend myself from something that
we don't have a vaccine for in the
beginning right yeah so but it's like
how is how is the health official
telling me like that's an okay
but this is not an okay choice like
there is no there is no explanation
there is no rhyme or reason you cannot
make that message it's
optics you can't make it makes your
business shut down for optics here
and then so that's the crazy thing right
because then then it's like we go to
court and i'm looking at other gyms
because there are some gyms who try to
fight back in the same time frame and
like they'll have
ten counts five counts fifth like like
maybe fifteen
of kova of i'm not a covet of it's a
eight point seven seven
which is saying like you guys didn't
listen to us you're open
right and then there's other accounts i
have where i didn't let people in right
which is not letting the health
inspector come in right
but i have that we're not listening
count 8.77
i have like i think like 60 or 70 of
them now and other gyms have like five
four you're also the most famous so
that's the thing right you're gonna
they're trying to make an example
because if they do it to you they're
like these other you you other gym
owners are smaller but
bradley for sure look what happened to
him and you're smaller but here's the
interesting thing right
at the same time in the same county
production
what we're doing here is okay indoors
and it's it's deemed essential
because it's entertainment right so if
the same at this like
the way that i built that entire thing
was through this right it's through
entertainment millions of views on
social media and all this stuff right so
at the same time that they're attacking
me for what i'm like
also should be considered essential for
correct right it's just it doesn't like
to your defense i've never seen a gym
with more content
creators than zoo culture there's
so many cameras yeah oh yeah everyone
has their own [ __ ] channel
yeah everyone i mean there's literally
like hey mutombo out of the way i'm like
what and then
yeah but so so yeah we have like there's
tons of people who travel from all over
to shoot content all the raw
athletes shoot content like everyone who
comes and shoots content for
the same purpose of entertainment
correct right and that's considered
essential
so i'm just like if they're over here
attacking me like i remember sitting in
court and the ladies like he pros on
social media every day all this like
he's continuing to break these things
and it's like
wait but then on the other hand you guys
are saying that like people who make
content in
facilities indoors is okay but like now
i'm being attacked for the same exact
reason that like you're seeing
see i don't think they realize what
animal they're dealing with you know
what i'm saying they just think oh it's
like a 24 hour fitness or a gold gym
it's like no [ __ ]
it's it's a different what we're doing
is different than those other ones and
it's more of a private gym it's not like
there's just no
a [ __ ] ton of people it's like it might
be busy but it's busy like people doing
specific things so in hindsight dealing
with what you
dealt with would you make the same
stance absolutely
well because it's because financially i
know you know i won't put your business
out there i know it's cost some major
products and that's the thing man what i
want to talk about too like i'll because
i'll get comments we'll be like here
you know you're you're selfish you're an
[ __ ] like close the gym down i'm like
hold on wait a minute i would be selfish
if i closed down my gym and just shot
all my content let all my people come in
to shoot content and that was it
because like what about all my [ __ ]
employees who like it's their livelihood
what about the kid who i was when i was
16 17 years old who was like
maybe i might have ended my [ __ ] life
because i didn't have something to do or
that kid can't go to school right now
and
his only outlet is to work out and shoot
content exactly and that's how he
just trained like i was that kid that if
i didn't have the gym i don't know if
i'd be here today
yeah so i'm not gonna take it away from
that kid who like i knew that i
like that was me yeah so there could be
kids in there that i i don't know well
enough maybe i didn't speak to them far
enough like
so maybe that's the position that
they're in or for some reason
those dummies posting those comments
they don't realize like when i first i
was like when the first comic start torn
during kovid
and i got so much hate and i was like do
you realize when i go into a city that
like houston san antonio
that staff hasn't had any form of income
in
months and when i roll through there
they're getting [ __ ]
paid men they're they're making their
rent they're making their mortgage
they're feeding their kids well let's
talk about this right like
number one there is there is zero actual
spread of covert in my gym there's no no
issue no one's ever come back and said
this no one said their family members
someone i know like no one's ever come
in
but at the same time like if you talk
about money
this that was the thing that really
irked me in the beginning was like look
[ __ ] me [ __ ] zoo culture right i love
look i i love
what it is but this is bigger than that
because what about the
thousands of business owners who that is
their entire livelihood
and they work their whole life to get
there and the government goes
you're not essential good luck so what
about someone's bills medical bills who
knows their kid has cancer maybe they're
paying for chemo like
what about all that stuff so now that
guy's life and his mortgage and his wife
and his family and his kid who's dealing
with this is not
it's just not as important as someone
who could die from covet over here but
that kid can die from cancer
and that guy might kill himself when his
kid dies from cancer and shoot himself
in the [ __ ] head
and that so those lives don't matter
yeah like how are you
how are you deciding what's essential
for someone else yep yeah like that
that's the [ __ ] up part and right when
i saw that and then you start seeing
like
you start reading about how like the
[ __ ] the you know all the big ceos
stepped down sold all their shares when
right before the [ __ ] plummeted
like they knew the [ __ ] was coming all
the shocks going down and then bought
their [ __ ] but like
but like we all like that's okay like
we're we're going to play this game
we're like no
that guy's all right got [ __ ] like
that's the [ __ ] up thing is like i
could have closed on my [ __ ] and just
filmed my content been like
you know [ __ ] this i'm just gonna like
ride this out like i don't because i
didn't need income the gym has been the
biggest liability
in my life for me for sure lawsuits
paying employee all this stuff i'm
paying the most like the most money
comes out of that gym yeah right yeah
i'm not over here banking money on the
gym
and now it's like i could have closed
all that down and
made incurred way less liability but
then it's like what about all the people
who really need it and then
standing for the people who don't stand
and can't stand because they don't have
enough money because the city goes
here's a fine here's a fine here's a
fine clothesline shut them down
yeah now they're like now their life is
[ __ ] like they're more
everything like their their livelihood
is gone i just my life who was different
yeah you'd be fine no matter what
obviously you you're not relying on the
membership of zoo culture you pay your
bills i i think what's interesting is
things start up you know texas
mississippi
florida supposed to happen soon even l.a
from what i hear is going to start
opening up more and more and more yeah
so by the time you get to this it's like
what are we arguing now that we have
more facts it's going to be tough for
what ground they're going to stand on
because a lot of those things are coming
after you for
we know from science and just just
experience
now through this covet period that a lot
of that stuff isn't isn't
well there's literally no proof like how
if i go to trial how are they going to
prove
that there has been ever a problem in
the gym yeah there's no there's no
there's a problem and that's why the
city's being sued by a lot of a lot of
people
i mean listen i'm not saying that that
i'm not going to be behind that like
yeah i'm going to be there
because i spent three months we operated
with a generator because they came
and literally turned our power off what
oh wow so we operated the generator
every day for three months
so i at least want that seven grand back
a month that's what they [ __ ] do
you know because we're feeling generous
i know about
and you document it all on your youtube
channel too like you going to court
it's funny because you went to i watched
you saw that video you went to court you
came out there's like fans of
[ __ ] cameras and [ __ ] yeah but but
like i i just
all these like super protein bros
i haven't said a lot about it you know
because like i
i don't want to i this is a crazy thing
man when i first started saying this
i just got to say this because you know
what [ __ ] it it just bothers me and i
have to say it sure
when i first started posting like i made
a series of posts talking about how like
you know that the loans came out like
you know big multi-million dollar
companies got these loans like i think
like
maybe 30 percent of businesses that need
it got the actual loans yeah but then
the actual loans that you got were like
they're only subsidizing like 70
of what the employees should make yeah
like payroll right but not utilities not
expenses nothing right so like
imagine your business owner you get this
loan because i i applied for this and i
read all the things that i talked to my
account what can i pay for right i can
only pay for 70
of what the employees should make so
imagine i'm a business owner i pay my
employees for however many months that
is but i can't pay rent mortgage
utilities
for of the business or for myself as an
owner right my situation's different
because i have other sources of income
but
imagine you're in that situation where
you pay your employees what business do
they come back to
when you couldn't pay for your rent
utilities yeah yeah so then it's like
it just so i i wrote this whole series
of like
like just factual [ __ ] right on my
instagram nothing like saying like
you know [ __ ] the city because like it's
not about that i was just like this is
what's happening to me
like help me make this make sense i
think you pulled it up on a thing like
you pulled a tweet up
yeah i pulled i posted that tweet like
in one of the other podcasts you did and
then i posted like a few like black
screens on instagram where i was just
writing these things like
like you know we're all focusing on this
but like when no one's talking about all
this other stuff like the
the ancillary damage that happens
because of it right and just speaking
like kind of like
just not general specific but not
attacking and then
well how come i hear from like my my
lawyer at the time otherwise at the time
that
the district attorney or like the
prosecutor like saw that and was mad
so it's like wait what like what are we
like so like now i can't i can't
you guys don't want me to like speak
voices
like the first amendment yeah yeah like
so now that's a problem to you guys
because i'm saying these things like
it's just like
what the [ __ ] is going on like what's
happening like i'm not saying
i'm not saying [ __ ] you guys you guys
suck i'm just saying like this is wrong
why is this happening yeah explain it to
me
yeah like and then another thing like
the whole gyms with the
you know the gyms where they're like yo
as long as it's outside but then they
just put it inside some like basically
like saran wrap with like less
filtration that's okay it's like
what do you guys think like and i'm like
what scientists told you that like
that was the right amount of airflow
like how are you determining that what's
outside but even though it's inside
what's the airflow like yeah
who's saying that like that is like show
me that data
i think it's really interesting as you
go through this what like they're going
to stand on yeah i just
show like show me the problem in my gym
show me the data saying the gems like
there's data proving otherwise
like so like why what's happening just
because you said so
yeah are they still trying to censor you
well i'm doing my best to like
not go out there and say all this crazy
[ __ ] until you get through it until i
get through it yeah cuz like there's so
much more i want to say man but it's
just like
[ __ ] it's like what what's happening
like i'm just so confused
i like if they man you're fighting the
good fight brother yeah
i just feel this i just feel this if
they were really serious about code
being a really big issue like if it was
as big of an issue as they've made it
out to be then why do they continue let
people fly and pack planes
i look i get it like because this is
protected i know i've read about all
this stuff it's protected by like a
federal thing like they're okay to do it
because it's federal but it's like
but if we're talking about public health
and why is that continuing why did that
continue the whole time
money my man like that's a that's
exactly yeah we travel all the time
and that's the thing it's just like
that's the thing it's just like i know
what it is but like
i don't what i don't understand is how
people don't realize that how
because you keep the people who are like
you're bad you don't have a mask on
you're bad your gym's open you're bad
you're this and they're everyone's just
dividing and attacking each other and
it's like
wait you guys cannot see all this
writing on the wall like what about that
like you guys are you're not you're okay
with that happening
because they didn't say it was a big
problem or like yeah they're they're
writing all these articles saying like
no it's actually really safe and all
this yeah
it's like i'm in a tube somebody like
yeah when i go to a restaurant i got to
put a mask on and then
when i stand up to go to the bathroom
but when i sit down and have this in my
hand i was like
and i can't give you cold it's all good
yeah help me make this make sense
yeah and it just it doesn't again it's
gonna be interesting once you
you know finally get through it man yeah
yeah good sorry i should get something
no i don't know yeah i should get really
nice i'm censoring myself
i'll pop off how about that when i get
off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this front
of a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song